wird hier raubtier ab bauer kommt
crafter kommt an und holz also weg vor
meiner nase berichtet alles braucht
etwas autos sich ist was sagt ich wollte
sagen immer wenn ich hier ich platz
unter den streifen schwert gemacht hast
also branchenriesen schweren und
manchmal passen entscheide fachwelt
immer blöd angeguckt hh bist du 70 ich
will jetzt einfach mal fackeln rein
überall in jedem stall damit den export
also an monstern dass münchen die hürde
in münchen ein skelett das skelett in
wien druckbogen dropped oder so ich
möchte mal 30 sein haus habe den ein
neues thema noch ein thema haben wir
nicht schon einzeln nicht erfolge gehabt
nein jetzt schon wieder da ist weil ich
der computersucht ja welches ein haus
immer noch fertig hat naja ich brauche
mal der jahrgänge sorry gibt dunkles
holz ab aussagen wie anders zu einem
achteinhalb dach das ist aber lustig aus
dem haus hatten wir das thema schon mit
rtl
also herr alters vakuums bunten menge an
dosen kripo ein video des explodierenden
höre ich habe eine fackel ein gesetz
einfach das thema von 971 anni also mich
würde mal interessieren wie die rtl
findest also so frauentausch um mitten
im leben und so und ob du das guckst und
so absolut scheiße dass das liegt der
größte scheiß den ich je gesehen habe
vor allem jetzt bei frauen weil dingens
war es her so bei handelte er und ging
in den keller
bei der supernanny da haben die doch
einen hund irgendwie gift oder sonst
essen getan damit sie einfach eine gute
story hat und das ist jetzt erst
rausgekommen 34 jahre nachdem nach der
ausstrahlung dieser folge
echt es ist ganz klar die wm jetzt habe
ich auch gehört aber ich weiß nicht ob
das aber keineswegs seine zusammengehört
ich habe sorge dass er schon ziemlich
gerade der typ so was wäre denn wenn der
hund stirbt dann haben wir nicht mal was
zu senden an der fleuth das landet
erhält das auch noch mal aufgegriffen
hatte die jetzt eigentlich betten da die
sonne geht auf zwar kriege ich die
schere zurück gleich wenn ich mit rea
wolle geholt habt uns halt in kryta im
haus problemchen moment aber guckt ihr
selber rtl 90 davon heißt ich habe einen
sehr mein zimmer der formel 1 auch keine
möglichkeiten kein fernsehen mehr so
richtig geguckt also vom fernseher und
weggeguckt also druck einige schräge was
einer mediathek oder so doch eigentlich
nur fußball bundesliga und auch online
portals online hat jemand animes er auch
gar nicht habe ich vor zehn jahren ich
habe irgendwann früher mal pokémon
geguckt aber so ganz manchmal okay so
genannte immer noch thompson anime ist
oder zeichentrick dragonball ist auch
cool fairytale sagte respektiv konnten
natürlich ps 320 folgen das vom blieb
das lieb dich kennen nur wenn man sich
die zähne blitzen lässt das ist du macht
natürlich im blick so viele krippe weg
ich glaube dir einfach zu den 1 dann
halte ich aus wie sony ce waggon nein
eben nicht jung jetzt macht es nicht
junge junge auf auf ich finde es hier
nicht schön hohe doppelschlag
eine gute erfahrung eine ganze expert
weg weil man kriegt eine luft gesprengt
hat ja meine auch so teilweise das war
auch nicht schön
nein etwa gar nicht schön das war medium
er und ein paar medien was war noch mal
das thema total kaka einfach nur da sind
sich die leute ja auch direkt so die
carsten die leute hier sind leute echt
beauftragt ihr in der fußgängerzone
stehen und dann zu gucken
der sieht lustig aus er sieht dumm aus
den kann man bestimmt genug genau person
hartz4 alkoholiker
personen neben zu haben sie lust nochmal
mit einem leben nahm mitzuspielen war
für europäer glücklich dort den
euroairport verkehr gut wenn alles so
dass alle das hat ja geschauspielert nun
eigentlich alles an geschlecht auch noch
mit diesen rtl bericht über die gamescom
aber ich finde eigentlich was war schon
davor ja weil er den gamer an war es
nicht so bekannt bei der youtube
community nachgehen dass dann bei
youtube community allerdings dass
sondern vielleicht erst los aber es war
ja davor schon ganz früh mit einem leben
ja noch echt und dann also man muss ein
ganz bisschen vielleicht stellt
mittlerweile ist es ja auch komplett so
dass sie so gern schreiben müssen alle
geschichten und personen sind frei
erfunden aber ihr spaß liegt beim gucken
liegt ja trotzdem wieder an das man sich
so denke wie der dann sind das ist
eigentlich so der einzige gott meine
schwerer alkohol eigentlich ein rational
ist weil man ja weil es alles nur
gespielt ist aber es ist halt der effekt
so dass der noch so dumme das ist
irgendwo irgendwelche leute deren da
denkt ach diese noch viel blöder ja
genau ist einfach hier ist ja ich denke
wenn auch ein stück leute sind nochmals
ist auch einfach so wenn du rtl guckst
denke denke ich mir echt oft auch was
bin ich froh über mein leben so wenn ich
sehe was die da so also ich weiß es nur
geschauspielert aber all das ist echt
schon krass was die dafür story sich
ausdenken sofort fantasien frank tausch
von fernsehkritik tv sommer sehenswerte
auch schon eben immer geguckt aber ist
eigentlich niedrigerer filmkritik
tv-film kollektiv für einen sehr
kräftigen fernsehkritik tv fankhauser
frank tausches von verstand sorry heißen
der ich weiß garnicht fernsehkritik tv
ich kenne beides ich kenne auch beides
darum habe ich auch den falschen
vollkommen falsch miteinander verknüpft
oder fragen tausch von fernsehbetrieb
tv-kritik erforderlich mit ihr leben
jetzt auch soja ich hoffe so viel
steht doch nicht genug holz oder wieso
bauhaus wenn ich dann doch nicht weiter
ich hab nicht holzig ordnung das holz
dann geht auch was farben anstatt hier
die ganze zeit und ich hab doch
letztlich gewann pflanze ich eigentlich
nicht fern sich direkt an ganz warm
ich bin auch am bauen von dem zeug was
ich sonst noch reste übrig habt noch
nicht sagen denn in sieben minuten
machen wir schluss waren wir sechs
folgen aufgenommen schon krass
ich bin auch länger müssen noch eine
traurige mehr machen mindestens damit
lag er gut von mir also ich weiß nicht
ob es heute zu eng wird aber für eine
folge danach habe ich noch zeit aber
danach will ich dann schon gern aufhören
weil anderthalb stunden auf nämlich
schon eine menge und ich muss noch
hausaufgaben machen
tut mir leid ich bin halt noch einer
spiel und da macht man halt haus aufkam
lag das sind bei monster hinterher ich
weiß dafür ist doch dafür ist doch sind
die großen pausen de luca ein bisschen
ja es war ziemlich großen pausen und ich
hab das letztes jahr auch so gemacht
dass er wirklich die meisten
hausaufgaben echt nach pausen gemacht
habe und so aber da ist nie etwas gutes
bei rumgekommen das sollte auch nicht so
super toll sehen märz gesagt komm ass
wieder zu hause weil komplett formierte
zeugnis von 13 schnitt also ein aus
meiner stufe ich habe den fall wie
machst du das in der meinte es
eigentlich auch wirklich kontinuierlich
an die hausaufgaben setzen und jeden tag
fünf minuten wiederholen
die nächsten fächer des tages man hat er
auch zu 345 welcher am tag kurz
wiederholen dass man das so gemacht hat
der letzten stunde mehr ist es nicht
ganz einfach mir gesagt okay gut es
macht jetzt einfach mal bisher läuft
echt extrem gut muss ich sagen man muss
sich dem system schule anpassungen gute
noten zu bekommen
sich den ganzen unterwerfen immer schön
nett zu den lehrern seien die
hausaufgaben machen
einfach einfach lässt sein weil das
bringt einen schon viel weiter am leben
nein es bringt ähnlich wie weiterhin
dort trinkt ein sehr viel weiß bringt
einspringen denn in der schule so
technisch weit dass man gute noten
bekommt ob es einem wirklich im
wirklichen leben weiter bringt weil ich
doch aktie bezweifeln das bringt einen
weiteren leben seit einfach immer nett
er als privater gründe immer buckeln
fahrrad fahrradtechnik hier nach oben
buckeln nach unten treten ja alle freuen
sich toll toll das nicht verstanden
ich habe gar nicht so sehr nach oben
treten weil wir so hoch gesprochen hast
mit deiner stimme so dass die
fahrradfahrer technik nach unten treten
und nach oben buckeln schön ich finde
trotzdem das hat er nicht verstanden wir
haben nicht verstanden denn auch egal
ist mir egal
hier denkt er doch einfach ich denke ich
nach über diesen über diesen spruch oder
wie ich versteh gar nicht was jetzt
gerade bedeuten sollte auf den
sachzusammenhang ich kann nur sagen wenn
wenn man im leben freundliches wenn man
zum beispiel person jeden morgen sieht
einer cafeteria und holt sich dann
brötchen und wenn man immer nettes was
bei mir selbst es sogar zu mir gesagt
habe ich glaube ich wie viel geld habe
ich vergessen
ich glaub ich hab was bestellt in wien
brötchen oder soll sie dann fertig
gemacht ich so scheiße doch kein geld
meint diese herkommen gibt mir beim
nächsten mal wenn ich immer scheiße zu
der gewesen wäre hätten wir das bestimmt
nich kostenlos gegeben dann wäre ich
dann da hätte ich dann hunger gehabt in
der schule auch wenn es zu kleinigkeiten
sind ja dass das sehe ich ja genauso ja
noch da sein und so weiter aber ich
meine allgemein sich die mühen system
schule so anzupassen mit dem mal gar
nicht was mit mit lehrer an geht es mir
immer das gleiche system oder auch um
oder auch im beruf eben buckeln
passend dazu hier rechnet die nummer
deichkind ja halt die deadline 1 fein
sparte das holz geben was sicher gut
gefällt habe kannst du machen das ist
das was ich hier gepflanzt habe könnte
auch mal selber was fehlen
ich will das doch gerade schon nein ich
glaube ich hab hier immerhin selbst
gepflanzt jährige und ihr raubtier abbau
von crafter kommt an und holz alles weg
vor meiner nase obwohl ich das alles
braucht es ist doch spark gegeben ja ich
gebe auch ein bisschen hätte ich ihm
bissen endlichen gegeben will aber da
hatte ich brauche es aber auch selber
alter ich dachte was jetzt ein dach zu
ende
ach so ja das kann junger sorry aber das
schaffen wir sonst nichts
das passt schiffen war ich muss mir auch
erst nach ihres jahr
er ist aus meiner sicht titel sind noch
gar nicht gesehen was hier überhaupt
drin ist alles so hoch ich kenne auch
noch schlecht aus ich bin werde ich die
bücherregale gibt es leider keine
probleme ich cool jeder bestimmt habt
ihr betriebsfertig brig allgemein bei
promedia dürfte oft noch ganz einfach
vom dach fredrik war ganz cool da
bräuchte ich ein bisschen was und
eisengitter alte aber das hier oben
willst du mich auch noch fertig bauen
oder was oben da wäre wo ich stelle
stellen von simples pat ryan dunn ist
gut die hände hätte mich was mir ja ja
ich will nicht schneller schneller
schneller mach mach mach mach mach
relativ langen regal frau auf ich hab
noch drei jetzt nicht gleich links ich
habe mehr was wie viele herzen noch
genug und ich ameisen schwert das keinen
cent wert
ja okay stimmt aber ich werde sicherlich
am 1
aber ich könnte mir jetzt machen was ist
das da warte ich möchte nicht sagen was
ist halt
warum ist eine komische wand hier war
ich das alles jetzt letzte durch dunkles
holz macht alles neu dass es denner 2.0
was oliver weiter an dem linksseitig
bäumchen hin
neben 100 mg an
es ist nicht mal spaß meiner warten auf
mich kann ich mehr wegbewegen der dem
was jetzt der- oder steht er bei euch
bei mir steht der dann steht der bewegte
mann töten versucht der andere hund
reagiert auch nicht eigentlich ganz
harmlos mit drauf
tacke kaputt so das gras setzt schätzt
hierhin schön ein bisschen wilder bilder
ganz eine schon wieder nacht wird werden
wir ja sehen mal die nacht überspringen
hat jeder genug für ein bett ich hab ich
mir als kraft moment ja traf sie mit
gerade mal 1 warte ich denn aus orange
wolle voll individuell und so wir können
gleich wieder neues thema andere sind
gleich wenn ich jetzt kritisch man
kriegt mein bett ist voll schön ich bin
obwohl ich in mein bett ist so schön
ich glaube ich fahre gleich ein bisschen
habe ich die fahne fach hier nochmal
dran dann kann ich das ganze noch
verlängern
noch mehr hey lasst die bäume aber mehr
hier stehen lassen okay die wie sagen
wir so ein besonderes feeling